lots of people bought Eclipse glasses
which allow you to look directly at an
eclipse safely yeah unfortunately this
is sad and it always happens but some
people
we're selling counterfeit Eclipse
glasses yes true story which is terrible
because you can seriously damage your
eyes if you look at the Sun without the
proper protection I mean it was amazing
yeah absolutely
tell me about I mean I almost got taken
in by some fake Eclipse glasses that I
bought from a guy on the street but
luckily I tested him before I used him
because I I could have really been hurt
okay this is crazy really what what what
happened Andi well you know what rather
than explain it I should just roll this
tape Billy could you roll this tape
please Oh handy hey Jesse oh hey Jesse
uh you want to check out the Eclipse I
got these awesome glasses that let you
look right at it are they safe oh
absolutely I mean they've been certified
by the eye doctor Council or something
like that yeah I'll give it a shot all
right cool
[Applause]
Andy the hell oh come on I was in that
take your teal oh I wasn't but I think
Jesse thinks it was a big deal right
Jesse
I'm fine Conan
all right well we have an excellent show
tonight star of a man with a plan and
the Showtime suit on the Showtime series
episodes Matt LeBlanc Jesse
from the perfect pitch from the pitch
perfect movies and the new film Bushwick
Brittany snow is on the shoulder
JT and Mike Kaplan's on the show we got
a great one
[Applause]
you